one big thing that makes me more
productive is bot recording 220
countries watch my videos and I put
close captions in 56 languages to all of
my videos it has opened a lot of doors
for me to become a better physician I
think a better educator a better teacher
my colleagues see me as an educator with
respect my prescription pad contains
take this medicine and by the way this
medicine that I'm prescribing to you I
have a video video and now I don't need
to spend 12 minutes telling them about
all the side effects and what it
takes imagine growing your YouTube
channel from Z to 530,000 subscribers
and imagine generating 1 million views
per month and having your YouTube
channel open up the door to
Opportunities like getting to write a
book with a traditional publisher
leading to new business and ultimately
leading to Greater impact in the world
well today's conversation on the think
media podcast is with Dr Andrea and I'm
so excited because her YouTube channel
is all about the causes prevention and
treatment and management of chronic pain
and she is impacting people's lives
publishing content and her story is
contains a lot of insights for how we
can grow our channels and our businesses
so Dr Andrea welcome to the podcast
thank you Shan for inviting me to be
here today so for those that are just
meeting you can you tell people a little
bit about what you do and when you
started your YouTube channel yes of
course I am a physician I am uh I
practice in Toronto Canada I am
originally from Brazil and I live in
Canada for 25 years and here I work in a
pain clinic so I am a pain specialist I
treat people who have chronic pain and
most of what I do is educating people so
they come to me they had pain you know
low back pain fibromyalgia TR is
headaches and tendinitis neuropathic
pain a lot of types of pain and uh they
when they come to me they don't know you
know what it means to have to be chronic
pain so I do a lot of education and
spend a lot of time talking to them and
explaining things so I started the
channel in
2019 because um I needed to educate my
own patients and I started recording on
my iPhone at home and I decided to post
on YouTube because I said everybody has
access to Internet and YouTube and then
I did um initially I didn't tell anyone
like I didn't even tell my family I
didn't want to look like a
YouTuber uh I was a respected physician
you know my career I am a professor of
medicine at the University of Toronto so
I did not know how people would see me
as you know like comparing me to those
teenagers who do funny things on YouTube
but my patience l loved it they really
appreciate it they came back to me and
they said that's so helpful because
I I it's almost like spending more time
with you at home and my family can watch
with me and I put the words when I when
I speak some difficult words medical
terms I write down in the screen so they
can read and they loved it and uh I I
guess more people liked it because then
my channel just started going you know
in a lot of
views and uh I think the journey has
been wonderful so far four years doing
this and I don't regret anything it's
such an inspiring story today you have
530,000 subscribers but take me back to
2019 how many videos did you post per
week or per month at first yeah you were
using your phone were you're just
editing your own videos on your phone
yeah and what was like the milestones
for you did how much growth did you
experience even in that first year so
first of all let me say the think
media I did not know about think media
podcast but think media helped me a lot
because I had no idea how to edit and
use my iPhone I was editing myself I use
Fiora and um I was able only to do one a
month one video a month because I was
doing everything and I did everything
2019 and 2020 and it was only in January
2021 that I decided listening to you
Shan you are my big
inspiration I decided to start posting
more and then I hired an editor which is
my son and then I said now I can go once
a week and I made a commitment to post
once a week uh it's hard I can tell you
it's not easy to go from once a month to
once a week you have to come up with
content but it was worthwhile because I
had a list of every time I make a list
list of how many videos I still have to
make it's always more than a hundred
videos and um it it the topic is always
growing there's always something to talk
about pain but if it was not for the
help that I had for my son being able to
addit and a lot of a lot of tricks that
I learned from think media and the V
Community I would not be able to do this
because one big thing that makes me more
productive is batch recording and I
learned this in v that's amazing and you
what was that first Milestone so if you
started in 2019 one a month is 12 videos
a year when did you reach can you
remember around maybe a thousand
subscribers and 10,000 subscribers did
it take was it slow at at the start I
mean no it really picked up probably in
the last couple years to get to over a
half a million but yeah I can tell you
the story uh so I published my first
video February 2019 and then uh there
was no big growth you know I I can't
remember exactly how many I got in the
first year but I remember really well
that when the pandemic started in 2020
March 2020 the pandemic started and then
because the pandemic started my mother
who has
osteoporosis she was in lockdown and she
stopped doing her exercises so on on
Mother's Day May 2020 I released my ever
first video of exercises and that was a
gift to my mother I said I'm giving you
this video for you to exercise it's
exercise for osteoporosis that you can
do at home you don't need to get out so
that video didn't get a lot of views
until October so in October 2020 there
was an explosion that video just went
vertical you know when there is a flat
line and then vertical October a lot of
views so then I realized realized that
it was my first video that went viral
was that one but you see many months
after the publication I said oh people
like exercise videos so the next month
November 2020 I release another video of
exercise exercise for hip and knee and
those two then push my channel up um and
then in January 2021 when I started
posting once a week I remember well I
had 10,000 subscribers and I was still
not monetizing because I had no idea
that I could do
that and then one friend of mine he
contacted me he said Indra are you
monetizing did you signed the YouTube
Partner program I said what is that and
he said you you could be making some ad
revenues and I then I signed the IP ypp
in January 2021 when I already had
10,000 subscribers but then I I started
listening to my audience I said okay
they like videos of exercises and they
like videos about diet nutrition
vitamins because those were the ones
that were going a lot of views and I
started posting on those topics more
than giving lectures about pain although
that's why I started my channel is
because I want to explain what is pain
chronic pain fibromyalgia those kind of
things but when you listen to your
audience what they want like bringing
those two types of videos exercises in
nutrition basically brought a lot of
viewers that now watch what I want which
is about the lectures of chronic pain
wow there are so many Rich nuggets and I
took a lot of principles away from your
journey you started in 2019 and it
reminds us that YouTube is a marathon
and not a Sprint was a a year of
consistency without any major growth
you're figuring things out but
eventually on Mother's Day in 2020 we
say do for one what you wish you could
do for all and you you actually thought
about one person not even on the
internet one person in your life making
this gift for your mom about what she
was dealing with in light of her
circumstances to solve one person's
specific Pro problem but then what you
ended up doing for her ended up being a
blessing to so many more people but it's
also fascinating is that it took time
and this is what of course we teach in
VRA all the time it's like once you kind
of start to understand it it's like be
consistent with the process of posting
videos around great topics but never
underestimate what might happen one of
your YouTube videos at day 30 day 90 day
150 6 months later and it was actually 6
months after and being committed to the
process and then success leaves Clues
you started seeing Oh okay exercise
videos are really resonating doubling
down on those and one of my final
takeaways was you listen to your
audience and that eventually caused you
to Pivot away from the content you were
making to content that they were asking
for diet and nutrition and exercise I
think th media podcast listeners could
benefit from first just sticking with it
persevering not giving up don't quit but
then once you start seeing some breakout
videos what can you learn from those and
once you have enough of a community to
give you feedback the content you're
making right now might not be the best
content ultimately and you may need to
Pivot and when you did so your exercise
videos your diet and nutrition videos
just started to take off and you started
to see more rapid growth did I get that
right kind of breaking down totally yeah
very good
summary amazing and so as a result I
want to talk about man how eventually
you wrote this published book and some
of the different ways you're making
money and how this has affected your
business but before we dive into the
nuances what benefits has YouTube
brought to your life would you say a lot
a lot so I'm not doing YouTube because I
want to be rich so I know a lot of
people want to make money that's their
primary goal I'm already a very
successful doctor physician I have
everything I need I'm very blessed I'm
doing this because and I'm I'm making
money uh out of AdSense and out with the
book but I'm doing this because I need a
vehicle of education for patients I
don't have time in my practice my
practice is very busy I already have a
lot of I don't need more patients and
YouTube is bringing me a lot of patients
because they they watch me and they want
to be seen by the doctor on the internet
I don't need more patients I already
have enough patients I have a very busy
practice but I want to provide the best
care for my patients and the best care
means spending time with them and if I
want to see more patients and and help
more people I need to see them in a
shorter time of Pur because I only have
24 hours in a day so if I can spend my
time with them in the clinic you know
getting the information I need examining
them and prescribe the videoos so now I
prescribe videos my prescription pad
contains take this medicine and by the
way this medicine that I I'm prescribing
to I have a video like emit trilene is a
medication that I use a lot for chronic
pain and now I don't need to spend 12
minutes telling them about all the side
effects and what it takes I say here is
a video that I made that I explain emit
tripin for everything that you need to
know about Emit triline and they go home
and they can you know because the other
things is at the end of the consult I
basically spent an hour an hour and a
half with each patient a new patient
they're tired they don't want to get a
lecture from me at the end of you know
one and a half hour being examined
tortured by the pain
doctor they they are tired they're
fatigued and they go home and they watch
that video me explaining and they live
with the Prescription Pad you know I
want you to watch this this and this
video it just facilitates my life life a
lot a lot and not only this but my
students I have a list I have residents
that spend time with me I I created a
playlist it's called residence start
here and there's a list of videos if you
want to spend time with me you know in
my clinic learning about pain medicine
you they have to watch that playlist
before they come because I'm going to
ask them questions and they love it
because they say they and this even
though my videos are for patients they
understand what language I use to teach
my patients they understand what I'm
thinking how I talk to patients and they
just parot and they copy what I'm saying
so they really like that I got a lot of
awards I in 2020 it was no 2021 I I got
a call from the pain Society of
Alberta and they said Dr furland you got
an award I said oh really which award I
have it here and they said uh it's the
first time we're giving an award to
someone who doesn't live in the province
of Alberta it's the first time that
someone outside of aerta got an award
and this is an award uh that the
patients with chronic pain uh select and
I said what did I do for patients in
amberta to give me this award and they
said your YouTube videos so then that
led me to another award the Canadian
pain Society next year gave me an award
I got awards from the University of
Toronto so it it has opened a lot of
doors for me to become a better
physician I think a better educator a
better teacher a better professor of
medicine and now my colleagues
interesting my colleagues see me has a
an influencer has an educator and uh
with respect so I initially when I
thought well how are going how are
people going to see me as a YouTuber
that stigma of being a YouTuber now they
see me with respect they they ask me uh
opinion I send some people to the V uh
course because when they asked me where
to learn they said go to the V that's
the best community even for promotion I
did not know I can be prom I could be
promoted at the University of Toronto
based on the influence that I have on
YouTube because people are watching my
videos from all over the world 220
countries watch my videos and I put
close captions in 56 languages to all of
my videos and that is because people ask
me my patients here in Toronto we have a
very Multicultural Community people from
all over the world and they don't speak
English so well so I have patients that
they ask me can you put you know close
captions in Chinese in this and this
language so I I just kept adding adding
languages and now my videos have
languages close captions in 56 languages
I'm sure some of the listeners are
wondering how do you do that do you do
that yourself manually do you just use
Google Translate what is your system for
adding the languages so the close
captions is a very interesting I
developed my own method and uh so I
understand Portuguese because I speak
Portuguese from Brazil so what I do is I
go on YouTube and YouTube translates for
you automatically if you go on the close
captions you can create so first of all
all of my videos that are lectured style
they are scripted I read from a script
and what I do is I upload my script has
the transcripts and then YouTube will
time them create the time stamps for my
scripted video so that calls with the
punctuation the
Comas once YouTube has that English
version of my script that is really good
I translate to Portuguese and then I
read the translation in Portuguese so so
if the Portuguese is good because you
know the Google translate of course
YouTube use the Google translator but if
you don't have punctuation the sentences
don't have a beginning and end and by
having punctuation you give Google
translator a framework what to translate
so it's much easier so once I read in
Portuguese I know it makes sense then I
just press the buttons for all the other
54 and then it takes me about an hour to
do this for each video and um you know
what I do when I am just pressing the
button I put some podcasts usually it's
your podcast the think media podcast I
already watched all of the episodes of
think media podcast and I just listening
the podcast and then just pressing the
button to do the close captions that is
a powerful method and for some um
that'll be a great part to Rel listen to
to think about particular content that
can impact literally the world 220
countries you know these benefits
mission one of the things I love about
you is you know our mission here is to
help 1 million purpose-- driven people
create a full-time living and a
difference in the world with online
video and we're so inspired by your
story myself and the whole think media
team because you are a Purpose Driven
leader and it's Mission seems to be the
biggest motivation for you just just
mission that you're on helping more
people um money saving time and the fact
that it has saved you time to duplicate
yourself so many entrepreneurs can turn
the rep repetitive tasks with team
members or customers or onboarding into
videos and save time scale your impact
you've obviously been able to multiply
the level of impact the awards and the
prestige um and one of my favorites
though that you mentioned was it's made
you a better teacher we often talk about
YouTube is I think one of the greatest
personal
development transformational experiences
that anybody could ever do because it's
hard and you learn you got to
communicate and it if you are going to
say something but you might doubt it a
little bit you might research it so you
are even better researched better
organized better structured stretched
growing as a communicator and saying it
it's made you a better doctor so many
benefits and then respect from your
peers and congratulations on the awards
and even promotion and really building a
stronger personal brand it's wild um to
see all of the benefits that have
happened and one of the benefits was you
have a story about listening to a think
media podcast and today you have an
amazing book it's right behind your
shoulder um and it's helping people with
chronic pain and it's on a traditional
publisher and it's wild because it's one
of the biggest aspirations of people is
perhaps to share their message in a book
but to think about a publisher even
paying attention to them can you tell us
this story of how even that other
benefit of another income stream
essentially but also another form of
impact in another another level what
what is the story about how this book
came about actually it was before I
opened the YouTube channel I had the
idea I need to pass knowledge to my
patients I have so much knowledge I want
to teach patients my patients need to
learn and I did not have a resource a
book to give to them there are so many
books about chronic pain but nothing
that uh kind of uh had my methodology
for Chron conquering chronic pain so I
had the idea of writing a book in 2019
and then I mentioned this and the dinner
table to my
family and then my son said to me Mom
don't write a book nobody's going to
read your book open a YouTube channel
you you speak better than you write and
um nobody reads books these days so I I
I followed his advice and I opened the
YouTube channel but then I still had
that in the back of my mind I still want
to write a book and um but then the
YouTube channel was taking a lot of my
time and I was happy and and
um and then one day as I told you I
listen to all of your think media
podcast episodes it was episode 64 I
don't know if you remember this
Shen I think it was April 2021 I was on
Spadina Avenue stuck in traffic one hour
coming back from work and you were there
giving 12 reasons why a YouTube Creator
should write a book oh my God and when I
got home I said why did I listen to that
episode because now I have to write a
book oh my God the reasons were makes
made sense I don't know if I remember
all of those but one thing that made a
lot of sense to me was once you write a
book you become an authority on your
topic author Authority I remember you
saying that and even though I am an
authority I'm invited to give talks all
over the world I go to conf conferences
people invite me to talk about chronic
pain I think having a book is something
that you can leave with them and you
mentioned that too you said it's the
it's your business card that you're
going to leave with people and they're
not going to throw away because a
business card is something that they
throw away but they are not going to
throw away your book so that was also
stuck in my mind and you also said that
when you write a book it forces you to
organize your
content great because my YouTube content
was a mess like it was all over the
place the other thing that you said was
also once you write a book people will
start inviting you to give you know
interview to Media reporters journalists
and I can tell you my book was released
last month and I gave probably more than
20 interviews to radio podcasts and
things that I've never like the amount
of interviews that I gave in the last
month is the same that what I gave in
the last probably year so a lot of and
and for me basically or the other thing
you said in that podcast if I'm not
wrong when you write a book you learn so
much about your own content that now you
have more content to create more videos
and that's true so doing the YouTube
channel and writing the book I had to
study a lot about chronic pain I thought
that I knew chronic pain in 2019 when I
started this Journey but oh my God I
learned every video that I make and when
I was studying to write content for the
book you have to go deep because
whatever you're going to write in that
book is going to stay in that book for a
few years right and you don't want to
write anything stupid
or something that is wrong so you really
need to go deep in
study and I so basically your podcast
changed my my mind so the journey then
went where how do I write a book do I
self-publish do I get an agent do I find
a publisher so I ended up um finding
another physician here in Toronto I met
him in a conference and he had published
a book for people uh who have
diabetes and I asked him and he he
introduced me to this publisher the
publisher is here in Toronto and this is
a publisher that they have experience
with my public because this publisher
they only publish books
on nutrition diet food and health and I
said this is exactly the kind of
publisher that I need they know my
audience because my audience is older
women um most people who have conic pain
are women and they're older and when I
looked at the kind of books that this
publisher publish is not like heavy on
text T they have a lot of figures and
boxes and tables things that are very
easy reach and then I approached them I
I I did a code call I did not have an
agent I code called the the publisher
and fortunately I got the president of
the the company on the other side of the
line and what was interesting I waited
until I had 100,000 subscribers on my
channel to do that call and that was
June
2021 and so June 22 as soon as I I
crossed the 100,000 subscribers I said
I'm ready now to call the publisher and
when I was on the phone with him like
first call I said here I'm a doctor I'm
a professor at the University of Toronto
I would like to write a book and I
mentioned the name of the other author
he said who are you um why should I
spend time with
you and I said I have a YouTube channel
and he said oh wait a minute and then I
I heard
and his keyboard and he said he said oh
you have a 100,000 subscribers I said
yes and then he oh okay let's talk and
that's our conversation started and I
ended up publishing with them such an
inspiring story and speaks to the hard
work it takes to build up the authority
of a YouTube channel but it's a
Publisher's dream and you know
traditional publishing is very powerful
and it's another level of authority but
self publishing is also very powerful um
YouTube Secrets is a self-published book
and um yes I'm excited and we'll link up
that resource in the show notes if
anybody is interested in listening to
that episode on 12 reasons to consider
writing a book um but now I know that
impact is the main thing that
drives you and your mission but the cool
thing about having a book is you've done
the hard work of creating it once and
it's also another Revenue stream it
could be sold for the next years and
years and years and I actually wanted to
read I looked it up on Amazon and uh I
saw Lynn Webster left a positive review
you already have all five star reviews
so they said it's just such a great book
but one of the things Lyn said is he
said the numerous QR codes for videos
where Dr furland describes different
types of pain treatments are especially
helpful this is an
encyclopedia encyclopedic amount of
information and it feels like a personal
offit office visit with Dr furland
explaining pain and how is best managed
for that individual we did something
similar we didn't use QR codes we'd use
like I think it's tubs
book.com a thousand subs or something
like that and we would link to videos
it's so it's so cool that as even
content creators we can tie our videos
into the book or the book into the
videos and create that experience just
to add more value impact more people and
so congratulations on getting all of
that out and it's so inspiring to see
the impact So speaking of these income
streams though now a book is one what
are the other income streams you
mentioned this is money is not even the
purpose because you're already busy
enough in your practice but I'm sure
YouTube ad Revenue have you embraced any
other kinds of um income streams yeah so
so far the yeah the ad revenues are good
enough for me to be able to hire uh
helpers and I I help I I hire people to
help me with the social media post and
that is and the editing video editing
and I have students also that I can hire
to help me do the research for the
topics because coming up with the topics
is a you know it's a hard creativity and
you need to do research and find so I
have I'm able to have students and go to
conferences and the book is the other
source of Revenue I have been approached
shun by a lot of products they want me
to do product reviews and to do
collaborations and I I'm still reluctant
to do that I don't want to because I I I
do products reviews and I have an Amazon
affiliate which is not a lot of money
but you know it's enough to buy me some
books here and there and give
certificates but I have I'm very
reluctant to do products reviews of
products that I actually don't recommend
I think there is a very you know
especially as a physician recommending
products people people will really pay
attention and the industry of
supplements the industry of massage guns
and pillows and mattresses and
threadmills I get contacted almost every
single day by one of them who would like
to pay me to do videos and um but I did
not open to that yet because um I if I
do I don't know if I will ever do but if
I do I do I want to do something right
something that I really believe and I
can test and it's not something that is
super expensive I find that a lot of
these products they're so expensive and
I I I
just I can't make that propaganda for
them and ask my patients to buy that
kind of expensive product because I
don't believe that they need to spend a
lot of money on that product so if I
really don't believe I'm not going to
say anything that is a powerful
framework we can all learn
from your conviction is what you teach
it sounds like is there's a few
supplements that you do recommend and if
you do use Amazon Affiliates I'm sure
some might be picked up at a pharmacy so
that wouldn't even be an affiliate link
so in some cases affiliate marketing is
irrelevant but it sounds like a lot of
your advice is
exercise um activities actions and what
you're saying is this multi thousand
miracle cure that a business wants to uh
promote is not something you believe
believe in and so you would if you were
to promote that it would be against your
values and I love the word you use
propaganda that is a powerful framework
for us to all to learn about because on
the flip side I'm I'm I think about
something like a
pemf uh pulse electro magnetic therapy
now I don't I'm sure you might even have
an opinion on it but some of these Ms
get very expensive right very expensive
and there's not a lot of evidence that
they work and uh you know there are a
lot of um things that are
when you look at the amount of money
that people could spend on chronic pain
treatments it's just
crazy and uh they the majority of them
there's no evidence from scientific
studies even for the
Pharmaceuticals uh the pharmaceutical
industry makes a lot of money selling
products but I just published a paper
today in Jamma that is about tapering
reducing stopping opioids so maybe the
pharmaceutical industry will not like me
because I'm teaching people how to taper
how to stop taking opioids for chronic
pain and uh so there is uh if my
conscience is not clear if I I really
don't believe and I don't think this
product this expensive product is going
to help anyone I will not open my mouth
and and I had to refuse very nice
products they would send me the product
they would pay me a fee
and they I would get a commission for
every product that would be sold with
that code that they would give me it was
a lot of money but I said Okay I I
prefer to sleep well at night with my
conscience clean and I know I don't need
to confess that in the morning when I
wake up that is so powerful it actually
reminds me I think the Apostle Paul said
I've lived my life with a good
conscience before God up to this day
talk about building a strong brand talk
about building a real Legacy and the
impact you're making that is very
inspiring and is a good framework for us
as we consider maybe a brand that
approaches us or different things we
want to promote um but I want to ask you
for those listening to this that are
maybe just starting they're under a
thousand or under 10,000 subscribers
what advice do you have for people
starting new
channels yeah so
persistency be you know trust the
process I I think uh if people give up
early that is the easiest way out you
know just say oh it's not working for me
but if you're doing something good for
the good of humanity if you're teaching
something if you're entertaining people
people need to be entertain people need
to smile and
laugh doesn't need to be only education
as long as your content is healthy
mentally physically and you are creating
something that can help at least one
person in this
world it's worthwhile human beings are
worthwhile investing human lives if you
can uh help them whatever solve their
problems trust the
process uh and try to improve like uh
follow what professor shano says you
know improve 1% with each uh upload
follow the V it's great your V method is
amazing it's so so well thought and so
structured and um listen to your
audience and don't rush I think if
people who try to rush and make big
monies quick they end up making mistakes
that they may later regret you may post
things that you will regret later you
can delete those videos If you regret
but um don't you know your image is also
important don't try to do silly things
just because everybody's doing silly
things if you are a silly person and you
want to entertain doing silly things
that's fine but don't try to do things
that it's not natural to you be yourself
don't try to imitate other people
because it's not going to work and uh
people will notice that you are not
being real I think YouTube is about
being real it's about being yourself
bringing your own identity my accent
people make fun of my I have a video on
vitamin D that everybody I know
everybody hears vitamin G it's my accent
and they criticize me oh she doesn't
even know how to pronounce vitamin G
properly I said who cares that video has
2.5 million views already
so uh be yourself don't be ashamed of
who you are how you dress how you look
like you were going to find your tribe
you're going to find people who
want to follow you and listen to you
trust the process I think uh I don't
have better advice it's fun make you
know have fun I I think sometimes it's
hard to be creating content week after
week but because now I bat record uh
yesterday I recorded four videos but I
there were uh some weekends like I
usually record on on Saturdays but
yesterday was a holiday here in Canada
was Victoria Day usually I on a Saturday
I can record six seven eight videos and
then I'm free of recording for two
months and then it's fun because when I
come back to record I kind of miss it I
said oh it's so nice to record again
because last time I did this was two
months ago and then I put makeup I go to
the hairdresser I apply makeup I choose
my wardrobe and I buy new dresses make
it fun make it like
um you are awarding yourself you are you
you know having making some change in
people's lives and look at the camera
smile remember to smile when you're
looking at the camera people will notice
people will react to you I think when we
smile at the camera on the other side of
the camera people will smile back and
when I look at the camera when I'm
recording I'm always looking at the you
know the middle of the camera and I'm
trying to imagine who is listening to my
video here is it a person with pain is
this person suffering what can I say to
alleviate that suffering a little bit
and uh and then I read the comments my
the reading the comments is my fuel I
would say if I didn't have comments to
read on YouTube I would stop doing this
because listening and reading those
people saying how I was able to help
them and alleviate their pain and
alleviate their their answer their
questions there are people from all over
the world sh that sh that they they
don't have any resources they don't even
have access to Physicians or
physiotherapists and they tell me in the
comments you are the only person who is
helping me that's that is something
right that is a big responsibility and
that's the fuel what really gives me
emotional fuel to continue doing this
one of the best answers I've ever heard
um and you touched on so many mindset
things and not rushing and keeping it
fun and um you also mentioned um that V
has been helpful when did you actually
join V and what difference did it make
it was May
2021 I did attend the you did the one
week uh what do you call that the video
challenge challenge yeah I did the one
week video Challenge and at the end of
The Challenge I signed up I remember
asking Heather Tes at the end of that
week I said Heather I already have I
think I had 880,000 subscribers when I
signed up I said do you think uh V is
going to help me because I already you
know kind of a I I I thought myself as a
successful YouTuber and she said Andrea
this is going to be gasoline to your
fire she could not be more right um yes
um I have now 530 growing and um 45
million views on my channel and it's
unbelievable when I when I look at my
stats every hour I get about 2,000 views
I said oh my God I I was just having
coffee for one hour and in this hour
2,000 people were listening in look one
day Sean I had to open I I went on
Google and I had to Google what is a
2,000 seats
Auditorium and they showed me like a I I
think it was an opera house that had
2,000 seats and I said this is the
amount of people who is watching me
every hour unbelievable
I could be sleeping and then 2,000
people are are seeing me it it's the
power is just unbelievable that's so
encouraging to hear and what a powerful
illustration I know many listening maybe
aren't getting 2,000 views every single
hour yet but are oftentimes getting a
couple thousand views a video and you
giving us the visual illustration I know
that we can all right now just imagine
picturing a stadium picturing an
auditorium picturing a theater and
picturing
just people listening that would be
amazing to pack out a theater and be
able to teach or educate or entertain
but we have that opportunity on YouTube
and to see how your channel has
multiplied and truly how gasoline has
been added to the fire so grateful and
you're living the dream I you've heard
me probably teach it a million times now
this idea of creating videos today that
can impact people tomorrow and you have
multiplied yourself because BR is
different than other the way other
people approach things where sometimes
they do want to go viral by jumping on a
trend but then the video goes up and it
goes down and it's forgotten about where
you're building this library of videos
that are getting views 247
365 impacting people while you sleep
impacting people while you're having
coffee it is uh it's so incredible I
have a practical question for you that
would apply for maybe some of our other
medical channels and also so maybe
service providers that have fiduciary
responsibility or or different things um
how did you figure out as a doctor
giving out medical advice and of course
you probably have to just basically I'm
asking you what do you do for a
disclaimer and what advice have you
learned about that when you're teaching
content that could be related and maybe
a disclaimer is necessary yeah yeah
that's very important that's specific to
our profession so before I start before
I opened the YouTube channel I consulted
with my college and my protective
Medical Association that's the insurance
so I contacted both of them because the
college is the one that gives me the
license so I could lose my license if I
do something wrong and the medical
protective Association is the one that
would defend me if I if I am uh you know
sued or something happens to me and both
of them were very supportive they have
already documents so my advice is check
with both of your organizations before
you open your YouTube channel and what
they told me is they already had
policies and they directed me to read
those policies and documents and those
documents were very clear that they
encourage Physicians to get on social
media they were not against so I was
happy with that and they said we
encourage because it's a service that
you're providing to the public you are
educated you have this knowledge and
it's important that the public sees the
faces of doctors in social media so that
was very assuring and then they went
through the the rules what are the rules
that you can uh engage with the public
that are safe and things that are
dangerous so they have policies on
disclaimers what you have to write in
the disclaimer so I have a written
disclaimer on all of my videos and I
also talk about the disclaimer so when
when the disclaimer appears on my video
I also read
loud I also have the disclaimer on my
description of the video and um so three
places but not only the disclaimer you
also they also have policies on how you
engage with the public how you respond
to comments and also not to disclose in
any of my videos or comments anything
that is private related to my patient so
if I see someone in the morning I cannot
come in the afternoon and say oh I just
saw a patient this morning and it's Miss
so and so and she has this and this that
would be a breach of confidentiality uh
what else they also talk about engaging
with commercial products how you if you
engage in doing advertisements
propaganda you have to disclose you have
to disclose that you're being paid by
the company so the person that is
watching you they need to know they must
to inform them but also not only this
they say you have to only do propaganda
and advertisement for things that you
really believe and things that you
really use so there are all kinds of
policies so I advise anyone in the
health care field to check with your
bodies wherever you are your state or
your Province check with them first read
those policies and don't be afraid just
go and put your face there that is a
massive takeaway for all of us I've
learned that a confused mind always says
no and many listeners to this maybe
they're not Physicians but oh I don't
know if I want to do affiliate marketing
because what if the government gets mad
you know I don't want my videos to get
deleted if I react to somebody else's
video because it's copywritten material
well when we have a confused mind we
always say no we're in fear I love that
you said don't be afraid but get
educated go ju go just figure out how to
do it and once you get that Clarity and
the information is out there we we C we
talk about fair use inside of v and you
can research that on the internet you
went to
two different sources um and researched
and it and got the confidence and then
you put together the different
disclaimers at the bottom of our YouTube
description we actually have a link to a
disclaimer and we do disclose like
affiliate links and sponsorships right
up top but it's also just a gen it's a
general disclaimer um and we've in fact
this inspires me to even invite some uh
lawyers back on the podcast a friend of
mine's a social media lawyer lawyer and
so it's it the the the takeaway I want
people to hear is that it's not a reason
to go oh it's going to be too
complicated it's a reason to get
educated it's not a reason to shrink
back and worry about what might happen
it's about learning the skill sets and
just the proper procedures because once
you have those things in place then you
can have confidence and think about
who's waiting for you on the other side
your story is so in inspiring I love
that that's ultimately what their the
the physicians organization wants
doctors want you sharing this because
this information matters and we're
serving people here on this podcast
where they have messages that matter
information that matters ways they can
help people and so get educated learn
what you need to learn get your you know
ducks in a row get your things dialed
and get your message out there Dr Andrea
you've added so much value here I want
to have you shout out how people could
follow you and I'm certain that many
people watching this are actually
dealing with chronic pain right now as
you and I have talked I've dealt with
repetitive stress injury kind of
tendinitis and tendonosis and a kind of
a pinch nerve from my neck to my pointer
finger on my mouse arm and your videos
even I think before I realized you were
in V you had I think talked to Heather
you had join later on you became a part
of v v show but I remember and even a
couple summers ago I was I rubbed all
this CBD Icy Hot type of um stuff on my
arms every day because I was in so much
pain and I have a TV Seattle residence I
would turn it on I would go to YouTube
and I would look at like tendonitis
stretches and exercises and you would
come up as I would search for specific
problems and specific pain points and so
I want to make sure people can find your
YouTube channel I want everyone who's
dealing with any chronic pain or knows
somebody dealing with chronic pain to
pick up a copy of your book so where can
people find you and find your resources
yeah so on YouTube it's just my name Dr
Andrea
furland and there's a the L to my book
it's on my website www Dr
andrea.com but the name of the book is
eight steps to conquer chronic pain a
doctor's guide to lifelong relief
amazing and so I encourage you check out
everything in the show notes wherever
you consume the think media podcast and
Dr Andrea thank you for coming on